Free Speech cannot exist Without Limits  Free Speech Depends for its very  Survival on respect for certain limits  if threats were considered Free Speech  people would not speak as freely because  they would censor themselves out of  intimidation that's one of the reasons  that our law has never protected threats  if fraud were considered protected  speech then speech itself would become  meaningless because people could no  longer depend upon language to convey  the truth if obscenity were considered  protected speech it never has been in  American history but if it were  speech would degrade into the base  grunting of animals as people lost their  will and reason over to lust and as  communities lost their political right  to set standards